an intolerable situation for people
fleeing war and persecution so declared
Peter leader Mullah MEP leading a civil
liberties committee delegation to the
idomeni refugee camp in Greece the camp
near the border with the former yugoslav
republic of macedonia holds nearly
10,000 people forty percent of whom are
children they've been waiting there
since the border was closed two months
ago the situation is edamame is not
human way of life this is our political
and moral responsibility to try to find
a better solution what the delegation
sees and hears will feed into future
discussions on reform of the Dublin
regulation on asylum and on the
eu-turkey deal which has been active
from March the 20th it's been criticized
by NGOs and international organizations
and above all by migrants themselves
there's a lot of emotion lot of tension
against the European Union against
Europe because people say after March
after twenties of March there's actually
no possibility to come to Europe from
here since the turkey deal was signed
the number of attempted and successful
crossings to Greece has fallen from 1600
in February to a hundred in March that
may comfort the Greek government
reducing the pressure on their system
but also because fewer people are dying
trying to get to their country